[Music]
the Royals are very complicated and it's
a whole different lifestyle it's been
radio silence from the royal family
since Thomas markle's first TV interview
my daughter is capable of anything and
she'll certainly be a couple and went to
the royal family
Meghan Markel's dad fears he may be in
the penalty box with the Royals
Thomas reportedly hasn't spoken to any
member of the British monarchy including
his daughter last week a source told ET
his TV appearance came as a surprise to
Meghan and Prince Harry adding they were
not given advanced warning we have yet
to face each other face to face with had
interesting conversations on the phone
we talked a few times about Donald Trump
apparently a phone call is still the
only contact he's had with his new
son-in-law Thomas who has yet to meet
Prince Harry is seemingly bothered after
hearing Queen Elizabeth is scheduled to
meet President Donald Trump next month
telling TMZ quote if the Queen is
willing to meet our arrogant and
insensitive president she has no excuse
not to meet me
I would love to me to clean I I've had
respect for that woman since I was a
child
[Music]